you work here yeah how old are you 13.
oh my God is everyone allowed this video
went viral recently after it was
uploaded to Twitter by a pro-labor
advocacy group called more perfect union
which then pointed the finger at the
National Restaurant Association a Lobby
group funded by big food corporations
calling it a key driver behind new bills
letting kids work dangerous jobs sure
taking drive-through orders and slinging
waffle fries at a Chick-fil-A your dad
owned sounds like the definition of
danger
exactly like working in a coal mine over
the past year to help deal with labor
shortages several states have pushed for
legislative changes that would let more
teenagers work New Jersey enacted a bill
allowing 16 year olds to work up to 50
hours a week during summer break with
parental approval in Ohio the
legislature is considering a proposal
that would make it possible for 14 and
15 year olds to work longer hours during
the school year and it's one of the few
policies Democrats and Republicans in
the state legislature agree on last
month Arkansas governor Sarah Huckabee
Sanders signed a bill that eliminated a
requirement that 14 and 15 year olds
obtain a permit before getting a job
these bills don't primarily benefit the
big food lobby as the union backed group
that posted video claims and it's not an
evil plot to exploit children for profit
the people who stand to benefit most are
actually teenagers themselves who by
having a job can learn to show up on
time follow instructions work
collaboratively and manage money that
they earned themselves and and therefore
value more I feel as if I've learned so
much from this simple job over the past
few years one teen who worked as a ski
instructor wrote to the New York Times
for a 2022 piece about the reality of
holding a part-time job while going to
school I've learned how to work with
children become a better teacher and how
to help different people based on how
they learn new skills my job has helped
me personally in many ways I was super
shy before I started and now I am more
confident added another high school
student who is working five days a week
after school I have learned time
management so that I can get from school
to work and then come home and do
homework there is plenty of data that
backs up the claim that holding a job as
a teen has positive effects a 2016 paper
published in the southern Economic
Journal for example found that high
schoolers working 20 hours a week during
their senior year had 12 percent higher
earnings in their careers than those
that didn't although that wage premium
has declined over the years for
complicated reasons in a job teens are
forced to discover or build out parts of
themselves that are not required for
school home or sports psychologist Lisa
damore told the Washington Post last
year she also stressed that having a job
teaches kids to answer to adults who
aren't their parents because when they
do the same thing over and over there's
no need to grow we need to stop treating
teenagers as inherently fragile or
they'll become that way real world
exposure to the challenge of getting
paid to do things that other people
value will benefit them for the rest of
their lives
[Music]